prenons-le par le haut mr.
McCall, je t'ai dit que je ne l'avais pas fait dans la
maladie et dans la santé dans la maladie et
dans la santé aimer et chérir aimer
et chérir jusqu'à ce que la mort nous sépare
jusqu'à ce que la mort nous sépare
minute jour pas moi avec cette bague je te
merde  avec cette bague n'importe qui et
je m'engage envers toi pour toujours je
m'engage envers toi pour toujours
nous allons avoir un bébé je veux commencer notre
histoire familiale c'est là que ta mère et moi nous
sommes mariés c'est ta maison il
a de bons os et le  grande finale votre
chambre d'abord Jean 2:18 c'est la dernière
heure l'Antéchrist vient pourquoi ne
nous dites-vous pas ce qui vous est vraiment arrivé